[Music]
this meeting has really been about a
digital revolution but I'd like to argue
that it's done we won we've had a
digital revolution but we don't need to
keep having it and I'd like to look
after that to look what comes after the
digital revolution so let me start
projecting forward these are some
projects I'm involved in at today at MIT
looking what comes after computers this
first one internet 0 up here this is a
web server that has the cost and
complexity of an rfid tag about a dollar
that can go in every light bulb and
doorknob and this is getting
commercialized very quickly and what's
interesting about it isn't the cost it's
the way it encodes the internet it uses
a kind of a Morse code for the internet
so you could send it optically you can
communicate acoustically through a power
line through RF it takes the original
principle of the internet which is
internet working computers and now let
devices internet work that we can take
the whole idea that gave birth to the
Internet and bring it down to the
physical world in this internet 0 this
internet of devices so this is the next
step from there to here and this is
getting commercialized today a step
after that is a project on fungible
computers fungible goods and economics
can be extended and traded so half as
much grain as half as much as useful but
half a baby or half a computer is less
useful than a whole baby or a whole
computer and we've been trying to make
computers that work that way so you see
in the background as a prototype this
was from a thesis of student bill Butera
now at Intel who wondered why instead of
making bigger and bigger chips you don't
make small chips put them in a viscous
medium and pour out computing by the
pound or by the square inch and that's
what you see here on the left was
PostScript being rendered by a
conventional computer on the right is
PostScript being rendered from the first
prototype we made but there's no frame
buffer i/o processor any of that stuff
it's just this material unlike this
screen where the dots are placed
carefully this is a raw material if you
add twice as much of it you have twice
as much display if you shoot a gun
through the middle nothing happens if
you need more resource you just apply
more computer so that's the step after
this of computing a zeromus
that's still conventional bits a step
after that is this is an early prototype
in the lab this is high speed video
slowed down now integrating chemistry
and computation where the bits are
bubbles this is showing making bits this
is showing once again slowed down so you
can see it bits interacting to do logic
and multiplexing and demultiplexing so
now we can compute but the output
arranges material as well as information
and ultimately these are some slides
from an early project they did computing
where the bits are stored quantum
mechanically and the nuclei of atoms so
programs rearrange the nuclear structure
of molecules all of these are in the lab
pushing further and further and further
not as metaphor but literally
integrating bits and atoms and they lead
to the following recognition we all we
know we've had a digital revolution but
what is that well Shannon took us in the
40s from here to here from a telephone
being a speaker wire that degraded with
distance to the Internet and he proved
the first threshold theorem that shows
if you add information and remove it to
a signal you can compute perfectly with
an imperfect device and that's when we
got the internet von Neumann in the 50s
did the same thing for computing he
showed you can have an unreliable
computer but restore state to make it
perfect this was the last great analog
computer at MIT a differential analyzer
and the more you ran it the worse they
answer God after von Neumann we have the
Pentium where the billions transistor is
as reliable as the first one but all of
fabrication is down in this lower left
corner a state-of-the-art airplane
factory rotating metal wax at fixed
metal or you maybe melts in plastic a
ten billion dollar chip fab uses a
process of village artisan would
recognize you spread stuff around and
bake it all the intelligence is external
to the system the materials don't have
information yesterday you heard about
molecular biology which fundamentally
computes to build it's an information
processing system we've had digital
revolutions in communication and
computation but precisely the same idea
precisely the same math Shannon and von
Neumann did hasn't yet come out to the
physical world so inspired by that
colleagues in this program the Center
for bits and atoms at MIT which is a
group of people like me who never
understood the boundary between physical
science and computer science I
I would even go further and say computer
science is one of the worst things that
ever happened to either computers or to
science because the Canon computer site
many of them are great but the Canon of
computer science prematurely froze a
model of computation based on technology
that was available in 1950 and nature is
a much more powerful computer than that
so you'll hear tomorrow from Saul
Griffith he was one of the first
students to emerge from this program we
started to figure out how you can
compute to fabricate this was just a
proof of principle he did of tiles that
interact magnetically where you write a
code much like protein folding that
specifies their structure so there's no
feedback to a tool metrology the
material itself codes for its structure
in just the same ways that protein are
fabricated so you can for example do
that you can do other things that's in
2d it works in 3d the the video on the
upper right I won't show for time shows
self-reflect replication templating so
something can make something that can
make something and we're doing that now
over maybe nine orders of magnitude
those ideas have been used to show the
best fidelity and directwrite DNA to
make an organism in functionalizing
nanoclusters with peptide tails that
code for their assembly so much like the
magnets but now in nanometer scales on
laser micromachining essentially 3d
printers that digitally fabricate
functional systems all the way up to
building buildings not by having
blueprints but having the parts code for
the structure of the building so these
are early examples in the lab of
emerging technologies to digitize
fabrication computers that don't control
tools but computers that are tools where
the output of a program rearranges atoms
as well as bits now to do that with your
tax dollars thank you I bought all these
machines we made a modest proposal to
the NSF we wanted to be able to make
anything on any length scale all in one
place because you can't segregate
digital fabrication by a discipline or a
length scale so we put together focused
nano beam writers and supersonic water
jet cutter
in excimer micromachining systems but I
had a problem once I had all these
machines I was spending too much time
teaching students to use them so I
started teaching a class modestly called
how to make almost anything and that
wasn't meant to be provocative it was
just for a few research students but the
first day of class looked like this you
know hundreds of people came in begging
all my life had been waiting for this
class I'll do anything to do it then
they'd ask can you teach it at MIT it
seems too useful and then then the next
surprising thing was they weren't there
to do research they were there because
they wanted to make stuff they they had
no conventional technical background at
the end of a semester they integrated
their skills I'll show an old video
Kelly was a sculptor and this is what
she did with her semester project and
this is my screen life do you ever find
yourself in a situation where you really
have to scream but you can't because
you're at work or you're in a classroom
or you're watching your children or
you're in any number of situations where
it's just not permitted
well screen body is a portable space for
screaming when a user screams and
discrete body their screen is silenced
but it's also recorded for later release
where when and how the user chooses
[Music]
so I instead would like this this
student made a web browser for parrots
let's parrot search the net and talk to
other parrots this students made an
alarm clock you wrestle to prove you're
awake this is one that defend address
that defends your personal space this
isn't technology for communication its
technology to prevent it this is a
device that lets you see you this is a
student who made a machine that makes
machinery and he made it by making Lego
bricks that do the computing just year
after year and I finally realized the
students for showing the killer app of
personal fabrication is products for a
market of one person you don't need this
for it you can get in Walmart you need
this for it makes you unique Ken Olson
famously said nobody needs a computer in
the home but you don't use it for
inventory and payroll Dec is now twice
bankrupt
you don't need personal fabrication in
the home to buy what you can buy because
you can buy it you need it for what
makes you unique just like
personalization so what's that in turn
twenty million dollars today does this
twenty years from now we'll make Star
Trek replicators that make anything the
students hijacked all the machines I
bought to do personal fabrication today
when you spend that much of your money
there's a government requirement to do
outreach which often means classes at a
local school a website stuff that's just
not that exciting so made a deal with my
NSF program managers that I instead of
talking about it I'd give people the
tools this wasn't meant to be
provocative or important but we put
together these fab labs it's about
twenty thousand dollars in equipment
said approximate both what the twenty
million dollar does and where it's going
a laser cutter to do press fit assembly
of 3d from 2d a sign cutter to platen
copper to do electro magnetics a micron
scale numerically controlled billing
machine for precise structures
programming tools for less than $1
hundred nano second microcontrollers it
lets you work from microns and
microseconds on up and they exploded
around the world this wasn't scheduled
but they went from inner-city Boston to
pible in India to secondi Takoradi on
Ghana's coast to social movie in a
township in South Africa to the far
north of Norway uncovering for helping
uncover for all the attention to the
digital divide we would find unused
computers in all these
Isis a farmer in a rural village a kid
needs to measure and modify the world
not just get information about it on a
screen that there's really a fabrication
and an instrumentation divide bigger
than the digital divide and the way you
close it is not IT for the masses but IT
development for the masses so in place
after place we saw this same progression
that we'd open one of these fab labs or
we didn't this is too crazy to think of
we didn't think this up that we would
get pulled to these places we'd open it
the first step was just empowerment you
can see it in her face just this joy of
I can do it this is a girl in inner-city
Boston who had just done a high tech
on-demand craft sale in this inner-city
community center it goes on from there
to serious hands-on technical education
informally out of schools in Ghana we
had set up one of these labs we had
designed a network sensor and kids would
show up and refuse to leave the lab
there's a girl who insisted we stay late
at night her first night in the lab
because she insisted on having the board
learning how to stuff it learning how to
program it she didn't really know what
she was doing or why she was doing it so
she knew she just had to do it there's
something electric about it and this is
later you know 11 o'clock at night and I
think I was the only person surprised
when what she built worked the first
time and I've shown this to engineers at
big companies and they say they can't do
this anyone thinks she's doing they can
do better but it's distributed over many
people in many sites and they can't do
in an afternoon what this little girl in
rural Ghana is doing
[Music]
my name is Valentina cook I am eight
years old I meet it's not human
and again that was just just for the joy
of it then these labs started doing
serious problem-solving instrumentation
for agriculture in India steam turbines
for energy conversion in Ghana high gain
antennas and thin client computers and
then in turn businesses started to grow
like making these antennas and finally
the lab started doing invention we're
learning more from them than we're
giving them I I was showing my kids in a
Fab Lab how to use it they invented a
way to do a construction kit out of a
cardboard box which as you see up there
that's becoming a business but their
design was better than Saul's design at
MIT so there's now three students at MIT
doing their theses on scaling the work
of eight-year-old children because they
had better designs real invention is
happening in these labs and I still kept
so in the last year I've been spending
time with heads of state and generals
and tribal chiefs who all want this and
I keep saying but this isn't the real
thing wait like 20 years and then we'll
be done and I finally got what's going
on this is Kernighan and Ritchie
inventing Unix on a PDP PDP's came
between mainframes and mini-computers
there were tens of thousands of dollars
hard to use but they brought computing
down to workgroups and everything we do
today happen there
these fab labs are the cost and
complexity of a PDP the projection of
digital fabrication isn't a projection
for the future we are now in the PDP era
we talked in hushed tones about the
great discoveries then it was very
chaotic it wasn't sort of clear what was
going on in the same sense we are now
today in the mini computer era of
digital fabrication the only problem
with that is it breaks everybody's
boundaries in DC I go to every agency
that wants to talk you know in the Bay
Area I go to every organization you can
think of they all want to talk about it
but it breaks their organizational
boundaries in fact it's illegal for them
in many cases to equip ordinary people
to create rather than consume technology
and that problem is so severe that the
ultimate invention coming from this
community surprised me it's it's the
social engineering that the lab in the
far north of Norway this is so far north
that satellite dishes look at the ground
rather than the sky because that's where
the satellites are the lab outgrew the
little barn that was in it was there
because they wanted to find animals in
the mountains but it outgrew it so they
built this extraordinary village for the
lab this isn't a university it's not a
company it's essentially a village for
invention it
village for the outliers in society and
those have been growing up around these
fablabs all around the world so this
program is split into a NGO Foundation a
fab foundation to support the scaling a
micro VC fund the person who runs it
nicely describes it as machines that
make machines need businesses that make
businesses it's a cross between
microfinance and VC to do fan-out and
then the research partnerships back at
MIT for its making it possible so I'd
like to leave you with two thoughts
there's been a sea change in aid from
top-down mega projects to bottom-up
grassroots microfinance investing in the
roots so everybody's got that that's
what works but we still look at
technology as top-down mega projects
computing communication energy for the
rest of the planet of these top-down
mega projects if this room full of
Heroes is just clever enough you can
solve the problems the message coming
from the fab labs is that the other 5
billion people on the planet aren't just
technical sinks they're sources the real
opportunity is to harness the inventive
power of the world to locally design and
produce solutions to local problems I
thought that's a projection 20 years
hence into the future but it's the it's
where we are today
it breaks every organizational boundary
we can think of the hardest thing at
this point is the social engineering in
the organizational engineering but it's
here today and finally any talk like
this on the future of computing is
required to show Moore's law but my
favorite version this is Gordon Moore's
original one from his original paper and
what's happened is year after year after
year we've scaled and we've scaled and
we've scaled and we've scaled and we
scaled and we've scaled and we've scaled
and we've scaled there's this looming
bug of what's going to happen at the end
of Moore's Law this ultimate bug is
coming but we're coming to appreciate is
the transition from 2d to 3d from
programming bits to programming atoms
turns the ends of Moore's law scaling
from the ultimate bug to the ultimate
feature so we're just at the edge of
this digital revolution in fabrication
where the output of computation programs
the physical world so together these two
projects answer questions I hadn't asked
carefully the class at MIT shows the
killer app for personal fabrication and
the develop
is technology for a market of one
personal expression and technology that
touches a passion unlike anything I've
seen in technology for a very long time
and the killer app for the rest of the
planet is the instrumentation and the
fabrication divide people locally
developing solutions to local problems
thank you
[Applause]
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance or
held no value there is a place where
artistic vision is protected where
inspired design ideas live on to become
ultimate driving machines
[Music]
you